[音楽]
60歳真瀬の大冒険
私は3週間前に60になりました
2年前たら東京国際大学で教えていますが
前職は大手食品メーカーの管理職でした
もしも前職に止まっていたら
5日前
7月末日をもって
定年退職を迎えてみました
もしの魔法使いに習わなかったら
私が大きな
崩壊をしてみました
魔法使いとは
前の会社の創業者でインスタントラーメン
の発明者&6喪服です
百福の教え
人生
遅すぎることはない
についてお話し入っています
前の会社では
フリーエージェント制トーンがありました
第二の人生に向けて
そう期待し退職をする
管理職に充てて配色金を上積みするという
優遇制度です
金銭的には魅力があります
ところが
ほとんどの人が
平年まで会社にとどまることを選びます
安定志向なのでしょ
また知名度のある会社なので
ブランゴしこうなるんでしょ
私自身も
冒険しようか歯医者に留まろう
岐路に立っていました
学生時代の記憶買いが見られます
教職課程の説明会でのことです
いいですか
フォント方に先生になりたい人だけだ来て
くださいいい加減な気持ちで教育実習され
と迷惑です
[音楽]
それを通り
私がそうそう
退出しました
その判断に悔いはありません
とはいえ
教えることに対する思いは心のどこかに
ありました
私の定検を若い人たちに伝えたい
大学でビジネス半径の
は木が教えたい
とはいえ決断は簡単ではありません
この増資になっての冒険をためらう私を
鼓舞したのが
百福の
生き方でした
年間消費量が
1000億食を超えるインスタントラン
発売当初は
世紀の発明
魔法のラーメンと言われていました
その魔法のラーメンを作ったのが&もも
ふくです
戦後の闇市のことっ
百福はへ
長蛇の列に出くわします
その列の先には
何なのに値がありました
人は一杯のラーメンのためにこんなにも
並ぶのか
家庭で簡単に作れるラーメンを開発しよう
彼は5つの開発目標を掲げます
彫金
保存が利くこと
簡単に作れること
手頃な値段であること
衛生的で美味しいこと
中でも大変だったことは長期保存です
麺は冷蔵庫がなければ日持ちしません
し工作部を続ける百福が目にしたのは
妻が入植に揚げる天ぷらでした
音の油に入れた
天ぷらはからハッターに上がります
麺を弾くからです
もも府はこれをヒントに
後2しゅんたん余熱乾燥法といわれる
技術を編み出します
生麺を油で揚げることによって乾燥させ
ます
乾燥させた麺は日持ちします
成分を飛ばす際に
面全体に小さな穴がたくさんあります
ここにお湯が染み込むのです
インスタントラーメンが数分でできるのは
そういう理由です
まさに魔法ならん
それを作った
もう服が
まもの使いです
喪服論19歳のポッ時です
喪服の魔法は続きます
世界初の発付麺を開発します
インスタントラーメンを発布曜日に入れる
ことでパッケージ
調理器具
そして
食器この3つを
合わせ持たせたのです
喪服61歳のときです
私が入社したとき
もも府はすでに会長職に就いていました
日常業も仕切ってたのは
百福の息子の社長です
私はその社長の基調として7年間支えまし
た
その間
しばしば私が隊長室に呼ばれ喪服の薫陶を
受けました
喪服のはい初よくはとどまるところを知り
ません
世界初の宇宙食ラーメンを作ったのです
宇宙飛行士の外相1歳な
スペースシャトルディスカバリー号に
持ち込めました
百福
95歳のときです
人生もそうすぎることはない
まさにそれを体現してます
もちろん
日本を代表する地形彼と私とでは比べ物に
はなりません
ですが
最初の一歩を踏み出す
プーッという部分では誰もが見習うことが
できます
50代を迎え
将来第二の人生を考え始めてた私には
大きな勇気となりました
早期退社をして
大学教員を目指すという冒険に出ました
私にとっては第4てるんです
まずは
廃車た利上げのマンションからの退去です
日本企業の慣習ですけれども私が見つけて
きた物件を会社が契約して社宅として私に
提供してくれてました
廃車をやめるわけですからタイプせざるえ
ません
そこで私も
2歳までのローンを組んで
住居
購入となりました
またそもそも
中高年の就活が大変です
私は
ミンたんの変色支援サービスに登録しまし
た
自己分析から始めました
職務経歴書を何度も何度も書きました
さらには
ビデオ撮影をしながら面接の分連を攻め
ましたさ
教員を目指すなら教える
へー県も必要なとの助言を体
私は
語学学校の面接も受けました
そこでの待遇説明は衝撃的でした
は箱をではねぇ
1分80円だよ
70分重要だったら80円かける7所
50分授業だったらかける50
授業と授業の間もん
03場合です
前職では肌です口に入るだけで年収が保証
されていました
私には厳しい現実を突き付けられた瞬間
でした
幸い
ある大学で目星エーション english
の
非常勤講師の職に就こうとが出来ました
これまでやってきたビジネス交渉の経験を
散りばめた授業です
そして音としたら
音楽で国際系学を教えています
3年生の人たち
文学した時覚えていますか
ドキドキ巨60
その時に同じようにドキドキキョロキョロ
してたのがこの私です
おかげさまで今では日々
充実した
時を過ごしております
不可能にログ時に考えるべきこと
時間宿があります
[音楽]
絶対に不可能なこと
今ば不可能なこと
時間をかけて挑むことで可能性が芽生える
こと
48歳で世界初のインスタントラーメンを
61歳デー
世界発音カップ麺
そして95歳デー
宇宙食ラーメンを
開発した
青を使う
安藤百福
人生に遅すぎることはない
これこそが魔法使いや教えてくれたこと
です
[拍手]